on the hill tonight for the colorado
rockies will be the right-hander chi-chi
gonzalez gonzalez 28 years old
he's got
almost two years at the big league level
6-3 210-pounder and he's a four-pitch
guy he's gonna give you a fastball this
low to mid 90s you'll see more lows than
mids he'll
give you twos and four seams so he'll
sink and cut the fastball he's got a
curveball slider to change up here's
donovan solano see the average he's got
13 rbis and he's got one home run
1-1 pitch is hit the center field david
dahl going back still going back reaches
up and hauls it down
chi-chi gonzalez posts a zero in his
first inning of work no score as the
rockies come to bat on the hill tonight
for the giants will be the right-hander
johnny cueto plato a
veteran he's in his 13 years 13th year
at the big league level he's 34 years of
age
and this is what he has done in two
starts no record yet within the area 587
lifetime against these rockies 9-3 with
a 2-6-7 era
trevor story
good weekend against
the padres has really hit well against
the giants over the last couple of years
swinging three and two on trevor
and trevor smokes it up the middle of
base hit well you said you got to wait
him out that was
a real patient
a b after he got behind owen two so
first and third
and here's
daniel murphy
and murphy with a base hit story scores
and the rockies have a one-nothing lead
blackman will go first to third
it's always nice when you roll out a
stat like a 310 batting average with two
outs and runners in scoring position and
he comes through to raise it even higher
well murphy is six for his last seventh
plate going back a few days
one-nothing rockies as chadwick trump
the catcher will
lead things off against chichi gonzalez
who's been pretty efficient through the
first couple of frames
centerfield hit pretty well
back is
dawg
out of here
and this game is tied he hits his second
of the year and the whole country of
aruba is making some noise right now
they're dancing the funky chicken right
now in the streets of aruba i gotta tell
you yastrenski drew a walk to open up
the ball game and the pitch to ustremski
is hit high in the air to right center
field this one hit well blackman looking
up and it's gone
up over that 15 foot high wall into the
empty seats mike yostremski
the second giants home run of the inning
his third of the season
and just like that the giants have gone
ahead three to one but on the phone
belt lines this one into center field
his first hit of the year so that'll
feel pretty good he's got an average and
it's now a two ball and one strike count
on the right fielder is hit into a
double play and then singled his last
time up
dickerson goes the other way hit well
it is out of here a one-hander
and it's four to one alex dickerson just
blew philip diehl's mind because philip
deal threw the slider he wanted to throw
i bet he had about a half of one cheek
into that thing and look where it goes
tells you two things it's a live yard
too it's got some strong paws
center field
and daw makes a wonderful catch
dole with a dive a tumble and an out
david dahl coming on and making a
wonderful play to get evan longoria
so nolan steps up a line out and a walk
high fly ball deep left field take a
good look you won't see it for long
that's
[Applause]
29th career home run against the giants
the rockies are within a run
with that home run from nolan 29 against
the giants in his career number 228
overall he moved past his uh close
friend carlos gonzalez
so mcmahon the tying run 90 feet away
sixth inning the giants with one out
they're gonna pull the infield in with
matt kemp at the plate
pitch mack lines it into left field matt
kemp with an rbi single home comes ryan
mcmahon the game is tied at four
walters goes down two outs that'll bring
up david dahl and this ball is going to
be tough to get to
into right field here comes kemp with
the go ahead run
five for colorado i don't know where
that ball is going here comes still
being home
bottom of the eighth inning two outs
chris owings
high fly ball deep left field and this
one is gone
chris
with his first in iraqis uniform and the
rockets have hit that magic number
and it's a party in the rockies dugout
now
two outs but the tying run 90 feet
closer alex dickerson at the plate
high pop up shallow left field owings is
waiting
he's got it and the rockies hang on
seven six over the giants
in the first of four
and colorado improves to seven and two